1200 tonnes de pommes a récolté en trois
mois et le challenge débute cette
semaine les premiers fruits sont déjà à
maturité ok il d'abord les fruits plus
rouges ont compass faire une première
passe et les fruits qui sont abîmés par
les insectes et tout ça mais c'est non
on a une belle une belle coloration et
une belle une belle récolte en lui un
tout premier passage fin août pour
récolter les gars là l'une des variétés
star de la production calibre couleurs
hein on cherche les pommes les avec le
bon calibre et la belle couleur voilà ça
c'est une belle pomme très bon et pour
assurer cette récolte
hughes a fait appel à une vingtaine de
cueille dans sa bataille elles peuvent
bien impeccable belpomme hockey
tayeb est un habitué de ce verger quatre
ans maintenant qu'il vient y travailler
chaque fin d'été est toujours le même
petit plaisir son rituel ici goûter aux
fruits n'est pas défendu la beauté on
voit qu'on a commencé le travail on à
côté d'eux j'ai gardé un petit paumé
rouges bien mûrs
alors on a goûté la cueillette 2020
débute avec une petite semaine d'avancé
en cause les chaleur et le soleil du
printemps
de quoi satisfaire le producteur une
récolte normale qui se débrouille bien
le sucre est bien le rendement sont là
donc on est assez satisfait pour
l'instant la récolte prendra fin en
novembre avec l'autre incontournable des
vergers la pink lady